the united nations has asked the
international community for 4.4 billion
dollars to help afghanistan it's the
un's largest ever humanitarian appeal
for any country but it came with a dire
warning as well
this is a stop gap an absolutely
essential stop gap uh measure that we
are putting in front of the
international community today without
this being funded there won't be a
future we need this to be done otherwise
they will there will be outflow there
will be suffering
but in truth the suffering is already
there to see more than half of
afghanistan's nearly 40 million people
are facing acute hunger
in places like in northwestern
afghanistan's badgus province years of
drought have added to food shortages in
addition people have no cash to live
their daily lives
and as we see in the following report
it's forced some to consider the
unthinkable selling off their children
to survive
a farmer walks across his parched land
these once fertile fields in
afghanistan's baghdas province are now
dry and barren
two years of drought have left farmers
destitute and forced many to abandon the
region
there's no rain there's drought
i'd say almost everyone in this village
has left for iran
for those who remain
limited aid from the red crescent is a
vital lifeline
locals speak of times when there was
ample rain and snow here
but ever frequenter dry spells have made
water a scarce commodity
the economic crisis following the
taliban takeover has only worsened the
already dire situation
and the new provincial rulers say
there's no money to help
we weren't prepared for this situation
because the previous government left us
with nothing
and from an economic perspective we have
nothing to offer either
so we're trying to help through aid
groups
we've had meetings with them and told
them about the problems here
many people now live in camps for the
internally displaced like this one
outside the provincial capital
homeless and pushed to the edge of
starvation some here are turning to
desperate measures
these parents say they're at the point
of selling their eight-year-old son for
food
the children want bread but i don't have
any
i'm helpless and have no option other
than to sell him to someone else
it's a bleak choice now facing this
poverty-stricken family
who like many others have become
casualties of drought and conflict
and joining me now from herath is asunta
charles national director at world
vision a global ngo that is also working
in afghanistan
we just heard from a family that is
thinking of selling their child to
support themselves
is this a situation you are seeing more
of in your work in afghanistan
uh thank you for
having me here
yes as a child focused organization in
afghanistan
more and more
we are seeing children being sold
this is just because of food
lack of food in the country it's a
hunger and starvation and poverty
that those are making parents to sell
the children so that the other family
members
can survive
this is something that i have witnessed
in one of the idp camps
where a mother brought a child to me and
just asking me can you buy this child
it's just between 500 to 200 usd you can
buy a child in afghanistan because there
is no food at home
and these incidences
victims of this entire paralysis
it's just just hearing you say it just
sends shivers down my spine i mean
why should it come to this do you think
that the world has abandoned afghans
after the taliban takeover
this country has been facing lot of
problems
and say it whether it's a natural
disaster or poverty or displacement
climate change conflict
this country was struggling for the past
40 years
and in spite of having lot of
investments for the 20 years where
international community has been
contributing to the development of this
country which we cannot ignore but now
this is the third consequent drought
this country is facing which is which is
a huge crisis
the crops have failed because of the
drought and families have no food to eat
so there has been investment for the 20
years but consequently because of the
impact of climate change because of the
conflict because of every other factor
this country is in this
situation now i mean the un has asked
for financial help from the
international community but just
speaking to you i wonder what do you
tell the international community
and i think of the mother that you
encountered in that internally displaced
person's camp who wanted to sell her
child to you with her in mind what do
you tell the international community
what is the sort of help afghanistan
needs
no this is one incident you won't
believe when i was traveling to go
in one of the medical camps where world
vision is running a nutritional program
a mother brought a child which is just
bone
bones and skin that's it you cannot see
any flesh into the body of that child
and seeing that child i really felt like
crying
and that is the highly
malnourished
children in this country more than 3.2
million children are acutely
malnourished and really 1 million
children are really at the verge of
dying so mental nutrition is constantly
growing and the children are becoming
the victims children are dying and the
world needs to stand up that's my
request for the world today
why doesn't the world stand up
the world has been
working with afghanistan so
maybe it's the time they think
the help is sufficient but it is not so
the afghan children afghan women
and the entire afghan community needs
the world to stand up now
let's wake up let's not forget
afghanistan
let's hope that happens uh ms charles
thank you so much for talking to us
today
thank you thank you so much